I'm John Paul Dyson directed the
International Center for the history of
electronic games the strong Museum and
I'm Shannon Simon's curator for
electronic games at the strong Museum
and this is every iconic video game for
the last 40 years when deciding which
game to pick each year we looked at a
variety of factors the game had to be
iconic people had to recognize it it had
wide geographic reach and was played all
across the world and it has cultural
significance with a lot of people even
outside the gaming industry
1979 asteroids in the 1970s Atari ruled
the arcade scene but in the late 1970s
competition came from Japan the form of
space invaders Atari new to follow up
asteroids was the answer this rock
blasting game featuring asteroids
hurtling through space inspired by the
original space war game in the early
1960s but it proved to be a gold mine
for Atari raking in the quarters both in
the arcade and eventually when ported to
home console asteroids combine this
amazing fluidity of movement with
excitement the sound ramped up the
action ramped up the asteroids came
faster and faster it generated coins by
the bucketful and really made a lot of
money for Atari and brought internal
fame to Ed log and Lyle rein the
developers 1980 pac-man when credo Toru
Iwatani was eating a pizza and removed a
slice he got this image of this yellow
ball going across the screen
eating pellets and he thought that that
would be something that would appeal
widely across genders across ages not
only did pac-man do well in the arcade
but it became the first game to incite
this licensing craze that means fun for
everyone all you have to do is go around
a maze and it also had these wonderful
ghosts in 1982 ms pac-man became one of
the first iconic female video game
characters 1981 donkey kong donkey kong
in truth the video games - with most
important characters the first was the
game's creator Shigeru Miyamoto who
saved Nintendo when they're desperately
looking for a game to replace their
failed RadarScope with a delightful game
featuring a character called jump man
who saved his damsel in distress in the
clutches of an evil gorilla the second
character was of course junkman who we
know is Mario without Donkey Kong there
may be no Mario and video games to be
very different than they are today
1982 Ichi the extra-terrestrial et is an
example of a video game
that's remembered for all the wrong
reasons it's considered one of the
biggest commercial failures of the
entire video game industry it only took
five and a half weeks to develop due to
licensing rights and trying to get the
game out for the holiday season
the game just didn't play well legend
had it that after the game's failure
Atari buried thousands upon thousands of
these cartridges in a landfill in the
New Mexico desert that turned out to be
true during a 2014 excavation when all
of these cartridges were dug up each he
is often credited as a great example of
why the video game industry crashed in
1983 a lot of games were being produced
and the console market was flooded with
games that just weren't selling the PC
industry was also taking off at the time
but when people talk about the crash
they always talk about eg 1983 Mule when
people think of video games do you think
of the game's not the creator's but when
trip Hawkins found Electronic Arts in
1982 he wanted to change that he wanted
to bring the developers to the fore and
so he got some the best developers in
the business to create games one of
those creators was Dan button who later
became Danielle button berry but needs
to say that no one ever died wishing
they'd spent more time in front of
computer screen and wanted to bring that
spirit of a board game to a computer
game you'll do this successfully it's a
game designers game the one that is
still influential today shaping how we
think of multiplayer games for mass
audience 1984 King's Quest a game
development company Sierra online became
synonymous with graphical adventures
mainly because of the success of the
game King's Quest developed and created
by co-founder Roberta Williams who
became one of the most iconic female
video game designers King's Quest
combined the best of early text
adventure games with pioneering graphics
for IBM's latest computer the PC junior
King's Quest allowed players a freedom
of movement that they hadn't experienced
before including being able to move in
front of and behind objects on the
screen it's a game that appealed to
everyone both women and men alike and
people who perhaps weren't even
generally fans of computer games at the
time although the PC jr. itself proved
to be a commercial failure King's Quest
found new life when it was ported to
other computer systems such as the
Commodore 64 and the Apple 2 line 1985
Super Mario Brothers Mario first
appeared in Donkey Kong
as Jumpman it wasn't until 1985 when he
first appeared in his breakout series
Mario's gameplay became so popular
because it was so simple you scrolled in
one direction
jumping over enemies like Koopa troopers
and goombahs and tried to avoid falling
in pits which made it easy to play for
everyone no matter what level you were
he has appeared in over 200 games on
every single Nintendo console ever
created and in the survey in the 1990s
more children recognized Mario even the
Mickey Mouse 1986 The Legend of Zelda if
he first played Zelda on the Nintendo
Entertainment System you might be
confused as to why we're introducing
this in 1986 instead of 1987 but it
actually premiered on the Japanese only
Nintendo Famicom disk system as a
flagship game it was initially thought
of by Shigeru Miyamoto the creator of
Mario and Donkey Kong as a counterpoint
something that was a little bit more
complex it pioneered this open-world
feel this miniature garden where players
could explore the entire land of Hyrule
openly without having a discrete path to
follow it gave rise to some of the most
iconic lines in videogame history it's
dangerous to go alone take this The
Legend of Zelda is still popular today
even with some of the more recent
iterations such as breadth of the wild
and Ocarina of Time
[Music]
1987 Tecmo Bowl every year sports games
dominate the bestsellers lists games
like John Madden football
I'm purchased by millions of players
every year but early on football games
were largely absent from the video game
scene there have been games like Ataris
arcade game football but it was a pretty
boring abstract game of X's and O's
Tecmo ball brought two video games live
action two screens for players it was a
real hit in the arcade and also when it
was ported to the home console at home
Tecmo Bowl had bright simple colors but
most follows the action that took for
most in the game and that's what made it
really exciting while the teams in Tecmo
Bowl were not real the players were a
licensing deal with the NFL Players
Association brought real name players to
the game that brought an extra level of
excitement
1988 wasteland role-playing games have
been around since the 1970s first and
pen-and-paper reform and then a computer
games but mostly their fantasy games
things seeking places in dungeons with
spells and wizards wasteland was
different not set in a fantasy world but
a post-apocalyptic landscape one that
was filled not only with a little
but also a lot of humour as well
1989 Tetris Tetris was originally
created by Soviet designer Alexey
Pajitnov in 1984 on an electronica 60
mini computer but it wasn't until its
release in 1989 on Nintendo's Game Boy
handheld it achieved real worldwide
success the title is a combination of
the Greek word tetra 4/4 and tennis it
also has its origins in the game
pentominoes where players take puzzle
pieces and fit them together in a box
like puzzle tetris became famous as a
game that was easy to play difficult to
master Tatro is still probably the most
popular puzzle game on the market it's
something that people can enjoy not only
on their computers but also on mobile
handheld devices it's a game you can
play really quickly while you're waiting
for the bus 1990 Microsoft Windows
solitaire we think of computer games we
don't usually think of card games
perhaps the most popular computer game
of all time was a card game microsoft
solitaire introduced with windows 3.0
operating system the game was crucial
not only in ensuring that people wasted
millions of hours of time playing this
addicting game but also teaching them
how to use a mouse a device it was
completely new to many people and so
they could learn how to click drag do
other things with this device at playing
a game I totally don't play that while
I'm at work too you know not at all no
never have never have 1991 Sonic the
Hedgehog in the early 1990s Sega and
Nintendo were locked in a battle for the
hearts and minds of their console
fanbase Sega wanted to paint Nintendo as
a console for children they decided to
have an in-house design contest to
create a brand new character they came
up with the idea of this blue hedgehog
codenamed mister needle mouse who became
Sonic the Hedgehog with Sonic the
Hedgehog they attempted to appeal to an
older audience with someone who was more
hip cool resonated with Gen X
then with the advent of the Sega Genesis
and especially with Sonic the Hedgehog
in 1991 Sega vaulted forward and just
absolutely dominated the 16-bit console
market 1992 Mortal Kombat never before
has there been a game that's created so
much excitement or maybe I should say
controversy
Mortal Kombat with a fighting game with
over-the-top graphic violence that today
looks pain but back then outraged people
some of those people were US senators
the result was not only a wildly popular
game but Senate hearings that led the
development of the ESRB the rating code
that continues to govern video games
today mortal comas violence was not so
much disturbing to some people because
it was realistic ripping the spine out
of your opponent is not necessarily
realistic but it's because it was so
gratuitous and also because there's a
feeling that it was marketed to children
who a game is marketed to sometimes is
important in determining how we will
react to it as what it actually contains
Mortal Kombat helped not only boost the
fighting game scene but also created an
interest in games that really respect
girls at the arcade games like Street
Fighter 2 will be ones in which players
competed to see who is the best
Mortal Kombat has important legacy not
only for its socio-political effects but
also just for its effects in the game
world itself 1993 do anyone who played
doom when it first came out will never
forget the experience this was just
mesmerizing adrenaline boosting sheer
joy of blasting away these enemies
coming at you this first-person
perspective was revolutionary and as
revolutionary was the way it's
distributed the digital shareware the
download the first chapter play it get
hot John Carmack and John Romero were
the geniuses who set this ammo blasting
adrenaline fueled action-packed
adventure set the heavy metal music that
really just turned the video game
industry upside down doom popularize the
first-person shooter
showing how compelling it could be look
down the barrel of your gun enemies
swarming at you it was a game that was
impossible to turn away from and you
just had to keep playing as long as you
survived 1994 Super Metroid Super
Metroid is widely considered the best
in the entire Metroid franchise as
bounty hunter Samus you're on this
isolated spaceship going through trying
to capture pirates players of the
original Metroid probably remember that
big reveal at the end Samus was a girl
Sam this wasn't the first female
protagonist in a video game but she
certainly did become the most popular
especially of the era and was the first
to really be seen as a non sexualized
character when she's in our armor you
really don't care whether she's male or
female she's just awesome Super Metroid
was one of the first games to have
multiple endings 3 in this particular
case and it became very popular in
speedrunning communities as they raced
to beat the clock to get the best ending
possible 1995 command & Conquer command
& Conquer wasn't the first realtime
strategy game from Westwood but it was a
game that brought together in a perfect
combination all the elements of skill
strategy and speed to make for a good
real time strategy game today command &
Conquer really showed other
manufacturers that RTS is real-time
strategy games had an audience who just
craved the excitement trying to beat
your opponent while so many things are
happening all around you 1996 Tomb
Raider 1996 was actually a really big
year for video games with releases of
epics like Diablo and Resident Evil
but we picked Tomb Raider for one huge
reason and her name is Lara Croft
Laura was this no-nonsense Indiana Jones
asked character she was doing everything
that the traditional action hero did
except that she was doing it in hot
pants as awesome as Lara was she can
sometimes be seen as a sex symbol as
well 2 meter really set the standard for
3d video games with the ability for
characters to move in every direction to
jump climb swing and in this particular
case find some pretty cool treasure 1997
Final Fantasy 7 when he had or Nova's
Sakaguchi released the original Final
Fantasy it wasn't the first year old
playing game but it was really the first
to take it to the next level but in 1997
when Square published the seventh
iteration of their final fantasy genre
it really really broke the mold tired -
this role-playing games were mostly
super popular in Japan Final Fantasy 7
exploded the role-playing genre in
America and Europe the game allowed you
to explore lots of different areas and
as one of these original 4 Heroes of
Light as you tried to go out and save
the world from destruction you were able
to explore different areas find treasure
and level up all of your weapons and
yeah if you started out as a fighter you
definitely had a cooler short by the end
with characters like Cloud Strife the
devilishly handsome Sephiroth and Eris
whose death unfortunately remains one of
the most tear inducing moments in
videogame history
1998 pokemon red and blue 1998 was a big
year for Nintendo they released what's
considered sometimes the most popular
game of all time The Legend of Zelda
Ocarina of Time but in this case we're
gonna talk about a different game a
smaller one
that changed the way portable play
worked you want a little confused as to
why we're introducing pokemon in 1998
when it actually came out in Japan in
1996 that was released as Pokemon
ocotillo Midori red and green the
original red and green was only released
in Japan and when it came over here they
decided to shorten it to pokemon from
the original title Pocket Monsters
because it needed to fit on the small
Gameboy screen and it was just easier to
read there was also a licensing issue
because there was a Pocket Monsters game
already over here creator Satoshi Tajiri
was this huge bug collector when he was
a child and he decided that he really
wanted to give children in Japanese
cities the opportunity to do their own
bug collecting he had this vision of
insects crawling along the game link
cable that connected to game boys
together and this Pokemon was born
Pokemon is still considered one of the
most popular RPGs of all time and as
legacy can still be seen in the 2016
augmented reality game Pokemon go is
people walk around with their
smartphones and collect Pokemon right in
their backyard Pokemon also created an
entire transmedia franchise that
included one of the most popular trading
card games of all time as well as anime
series movies board games pretty much
everything you can think of you can
catch them all $19.99 Shenmue 2 the non
gamer Shenmue sounds like maybe a killer
whale but in reality it's one of the
most exciting open-world games ever
created a real pioneer which players
were lost in a world which they could do
all sorts of things from battling
enemies to racing forklifts Shenmue
liberated players to explore in ways
that they hadn't really explored before
is designer Yu Suzuki with a brilliant
designer who knew how to make world seem
to come alive in ways that really taks
the limits of the sega dreamcast for
players or the revelation of how immerse
a videogame world could be 2000 the Sims
one of the geniuses that will write is
that he looked for inspirations in the
everyday world his hit game SimCity drew
on the way that a model trains app can
bring alive a miniature world similarly
with the sims he found a dollhouse
inspiration for a new way of playing one
that really changed the way we look at
how sims work in the worlds that they
can create people have been playing with
doll houses for centuries but the Sims
brought alive worlds of players who
interacted with each other had emotions
and did mundane everyday things like
going to work or using the bathroom the
game was strangely compelling players
for hours building their Sims up seeing
them interact with each other and really
creating this digital world that felt
alive the realism of the emotions that
the Sims felt and related to one another
2001 halo combat Evolved a game called
Goldeneye on the Nintendo 64 showed that
first-person shooters could be
successful on consoles in 2001 when
Microsoft broke into the home console
market with their Xbox they perfected it
or at least came really really close
halo was a game that broke the
boundaries of what a traditional
first-person shooter could be it had a
sweeping plotline a highly developed
world and characters that players really
really bonded with and also pioneered
some new game mechanics like the idea of
only being able to carry two weapons at
a time
that forced players to assess and
reassess every situation that they went
into in order to make sure that they had
the correct weapon he will became known
as the Xbox's killer app which basically
means that the console might not have
sold nearly so well without it in fact a
full 50% of Xbox consoles sold in
conjunction with a copy of the Halo game
halo also became extraordinarily famous
for its multiplayer
which way'd seemed odd because it
actually came out before the advent of
Xbox Live and players had to play on a
local area network connection but it
allowed up to 16 people to play
simultaneously which was huge for a
console at the time it may be an
exaggeration to say that the fate of the
Xbox franchise rested on halo but not
that much of an exaggeration the game
was really instrumental
cementing not only the platform success
but an image of what sort of player
really gravitated towards the xbox 2002
Metal Gear Solid 2 video games you built
around speed action and less so stealth
but the Metal Gear Solid franchise
really was key in bringing that game
mechanic to popularity and yet this game
had his own form of stealth Metal Gear
Solid 2 reshaped the face of stealth
games Hideo Kojima's brilliant game
really brought the artistry of a stealth
game with his different demands and a
player to new height that hadn't been
reached before middle gear solid is the
most enduring stealth franchise in video
games and Metal Gear Solid 2 was key to
making that happen
2003 call of duty world war 2 is often
known as a good war with clear
protagonists and antagonists the result
is that it's easily ported over to video
games but no game has ever done it as
well
perhaps as Call of Duty it put players
position to fight the enemy in a way
that was thrilling and the time highly
realistic just as generations earlier
little kids have played with little
green army men in their sand boxes now
kids all grown up have an amazing time
playing in this world a world war 2
which you're trying to fight the enemy
and stay alive as a franchise Call of
Duty has been a tremendous hit for
Activision and some of the best-selling
games of all time 2004 world of warcraft
in 1997 richard garriott coined the term
massively multiplayer online
role-playing game or MMORPG for sure for
his game Ultima Online but it wasn't
until 2004 when Blizzard released World
of Warcraft when the genre really took
hold with its peak of 12 million players
wow really took the internet by storm
not only was it an easier RPG which
allowed players who maybe wouldn't be so
interested in an in-depth role-playing
game to play it also made it super easy
for people to catch up with lots of XP
giving quests and not huge penalties
when you died it made novice players
able to catch up to the more experienced
companions a lot faster than normal
World of Warcraft is still the most
iconic MMORPG on the map when people
think of MMOs
they still think of World of Warcraft
first 2005 Guitar Hero in video games
it's all about the controller think
about the simple Atari joystick or the
controller for the NES but most
controllers are variations on a theme
with guitar hero players got something
completely different here with a
simulated guitar - anyone could pick up
and know sort of what to do with pretty
much right away Guitar Hero was a party
game that expanded the reach of video
games anyone at a social gathering
wanted to pick up that guitar and play
and try to see how they do even if in
the end they probably didn't hit all the
right notes 2006 Wii Sports you probably
have an idea in your head when someone
says I'm a video gamer and the first
thing you think of is probably not your
90 year old grandmother but when it
comes to we sports you might as well
think about her because she's probably
playing it along with all of her
grandkids Wii Sports became one of the
most popular sports games and one of the
most popular games of all time and
launched the Nintendo Wii console -
massive success in fact there were lots
of people who were buying in the
Nintendo Wii who didn't even know that
it could play a different game
Wii Sports helps the Nintendo Wii sell
over a hundred million consoles and it's
motion control remote and nunchuck even
spurred Microsoft and Sony who design
their own motion control system the
Microsoft Kinect and the PlayStation
Move 2007 portal in 2007 valve
corporation released a really
interesting almost funny-looking game
called the orange box it was a
compilation of five games four of them
were first-person shooters from some of
their more popular franchises like
half-life 2 and Team Fortress 2 and
there was this short puzzle game called
portal surprisingly enough that small
game which could be completed in four
hours or less ended up receiving more
critical acclaim than the other four
games put together portal had a unique
gameplay system using portal guns which
allowed the player to shoot in one area
and move in
right direction so you could exit one
room in one direction and enter another
in the opposite direction or in fact
move through walls and ceilings
but one of the most enduring parts of
portal was its single vocalist her name
was Ellen McLain and she played a darkly
sarcastic artificial intelligence named
GLaDOS who promised to navigate you
through the Aperture Science Lab and as
long as you performed to her
satisfaction you would be rewarded with
a delicious slice of black forest cake
unfortunately the cake was a lie she
actually tried to kill you 2008 World of
Goo video games especially starting in
the 1990s for me by massive teams
pouring massive amounts of money in the
development of the game but starting in
the early 2000s new tools began to
emerge
it allowed single individuals or small
teams to create a game one of those
games is World of Goo a fun splattering
game that really had a playful third
about it and yet low budget looking
animations the result was something
attainable yet fun and really spurred
the indie game movement it really is a
key player in today's video game world
2009 Angry Birds it's the first game
that really transcended mobile gaming
not only inspire people sometimes to buy
a phone itself but also by lots of other
merchandise inspired by the game Angry
Birds was important not only for its
popularity but the way it brought new
gamers into the fold of gaming someone
who would never consider themselves a
gamer found themselves addicted to Angry
Birds eager just to see if they could
knock down those devilish pigs and
really try to get the next level in the
game that was a frustrating fascinating
and most of all bond 2010 dark craft 2
wings of Liberty Starcraft is one of the
best examples of the real-time strategy
genre I think a lot of the most popular
realtime strategy games it takes place
in space with three very distinct races
humans Protoss and Zerg one of the
things that sets Starcraft apart from
its contemporaries was the fact that
each faction
uniquely different in how you could
build your bases lead your armies and
what your powers were the original
Starcraft also pioneered what we call
today the in-game sports movement the
eSports movement was especially popular
in South Korea but with Starcraft 2 it
branched out and became one of the most
popular eSport games worldwide 2011
minecraft a Lego brick affords a lot
more variety to play than a talking
Barbie both can be fun but one opens up
many more possibilities minecraft was a
Lego brick of the videogame universe had
simple 8-bit looking graphics that
opened up a creative world for players
to build things that they could imagine
in ways they couldn't build in real life
with those atom based Lego bricks result
was a game that has yielded millions of
hours of gameplay as players discover
the possibilities of building something
on the computer screen that before they
could only imagine 2012 journey 7 a vast
desert where the player feels small
against this wide expanse of sand and
tall mountains journey evokes the sense
of solitude and wonder players are
allowed to communicate with each other
only through chimes not to avoid our
text they can help each other but never
hinder the game was also designed to be
so simplistic that players wouldn't
require any in-game instruction so they
wouldn't be taken out of their world
journey is also known for its sweeping
evocative soundtrack which was the first
video game to be nominated for a Grammy
Award
[Music]
2013 The Last of Us early video games
were long on play and shortened story
there's not much story in Donkey Kong
the damsel in distress jump man rescuing
his loss yeah as games have developed
over time the stories have gotten more
compelling in studios have learned how
to tell those stories more effectively
The Last of Us in some ways used to a
very standard genre the zombie
apocalypse with many video games there
were artificial mechanics and move the
story along may you get to a new level
for instance your character gains new
abilities but the Last of Us you were in
the story always is your main character
and a girl who was his sidekick went
through the story developing almost like
a novel it was compelling because it
felt real in a way that where artificial
systems would not have 2014 destiny
destiny was developed by Bungie best
known for their Halo franchise and with
destiny they created yet another hit
perhaps best known for its persistent
online world which means that things
continuously happen even when you're not
logged on destiny creates a world where
players can do their own thing but also
just randomly meet up with other people
for worldwide events maybe there's a
boss fight that pops up or a raid that
needs to be completed
everyone can interact or you can ignore
it and just keep on doing what you're
doing the choice is up to you
Bungie also made a commitment with
destiny that it was going to be
continuously updated they said until the
end of time but probably at least until
the company goes out of business because
of that destiny receives continuous
updates and support so players never
have to worry that they're gonna run out
of new content 2015 undertale most video
games are developed by a whole crowd of
people or at the very at least one or
two undertale
was developed published written and
composed by a single person toby fox he
created a game that he wanted to play
and if there was an element in a game
that he didn't like he just didn't
include it so for example he hated fetch
quests because it made you go back and
retread old ground he also hated being
forced to grind for experience points so
none of those things appeared in
undertale one thing that did however
was a very interesting game mechanic
that allowed you three choices whenever
you faced a monster you could fight them
and kill them like normally what in a
video game but you could also choose to
flee or you could choose to befriend
them and depending on your choice and
your various choices throughout the game
you received a different ending that
could sometimes even continue on to
subsequent plays if you decided to play
the game over again 2016 that dragon
cancer when trip Hawkins first started
Electronic Arts he ran a series of ads
ask the question can a game make you cry
with that dragon cancer there was a game
that really had the potential to move
players to tears in large part because
it was based on the real-life
experiences the developer who lost his
son that dragon cancer brought to the
videogame the tragedy and sometimes a
tedium what it was like to wait with a
sick child to experience out it's a game
that anyone who played it could not
forget it's a game that began to show
the power of the medium as it developed
to bring new senses of what was possible
in video games new ways to move players
and new ways to show the artistry and
the pathos that is possible in video
games 2017 fortnight the most important
games sometimes aren't the first games
to adapt a certain media take the battle
royale mode of video games fortnight was
not the first game to use a battle
royale mode which you're the last player
standing say something like Hunger Games
for instance but something about
fortnight was compelling well maybe
that's something with fact it was
free-to-play and also the fact that had
graphics that were accessible to anyone
meanwhile a circle is shrinking limiting
the amount of space you can go meaning
that in the end only one person will
survive who's not the first battle
royale game but something about the game
that combination of fast action of
suspense of accessible graphics and the
free-to-play mode made a video game
phenomenon about new players in about
players of all ages together to play
2018 celeste some games you just enjoy
playing there's not really as much rhyme
or reason for it you just really like it
celeste tended to
one of those with the gamers for whom it
was popular Celeste had some interesting
game mechanics that allowed you to do
things like double dash in midair it
wasn't the first game to do that but
combined with the fact that each room
with its own individual puzzle it made
everything feel faster stronger and it
also allowed for a great deal of
replayability since each room had maybe
a different way to play it several rooms
also had hidden cassette tapes if he
found a cassette tape it would unlock a
b-side to the level which was a harder
version if you beat every single b-side
it unlocked a seaside and allowed you to
play an even harder version basically
allowing for almost endless
replayability of the game but what
really hooked a lot of players to
Celeste was the protagonist herself a
young girl named Madeline who was trying
desperately to scale a mountain
she kept being hindered by a reflection
of herself that she called a piece of me
it turned out that this piece of her was
a metaphor for her own internal anxiety
and depression and it was only by
combining the two aspects of herself
that she was able to finally scale the
mountain which is a really interesting
metaphor I think for most of us there
was every iconic game for the past 40
years we hope you learned something and
had some fun doing it we'll look forward
to seeing with the next 40 years brain